а все могло бути трошки інакше
пам'ятаєте Я три роки тому стояв на цій
трибуні і казав про те що є докази про
те що
нинішнє керівництво держави тодішні
нинішня зірвало операцію унікальну
спецоперацію спецслужб із затримання
і вилучення вагнерівців і засудження
можливого їх потім в Україні
було дуже багато розмов було дуже багато
засідань тимчасової слідчої комісії була
зареєстрована і постанова три роки тому
яку можна було тоді прийняти
але тоді оскільки це стосувалося вищих
керівних осіб держави вирішили так
замяти трошечки спустити на гальма
десь пом'якшити десь взагалі завалювати
але якщо ми сьогодні
двагенерівці були в тюрмі в українській
То була би зовсім інша ситуація і
можливо би міжнародні структури які би
отримали в 2020 році всі необхідні
свідчення і докази про злочини
вагнерівців в Україні у 14-16 роках і
поставилися би інакше до того як
Росія готувала своє вторгнення в Україну
починаючи із
2019 року
і тому я хочу сказати нам сьогодні треба
обов'язково проголосувати за ті
постанови які ми сьогодні розглядаємо
але дуже велика ціна помилок коли за
цими помилками стоять конкретні особи із
числа вищого керівництва країни
Пам'ятайте про це